why is it controlling how about a guy
just has some standards for himself and
he's saying to himself if I'm going to
date you and we're going to be exclusive
and I'm going to prioritize you in
multiple ways I have expectations of you
which means that you're not going to go
out get sloppy drunk with your friends
be around a bunch of guys that are going
to be like ah the whole time
and maybe behave badly because people
make not so great decisions when they
drink and why are you putting yourself
in that situation I don't want to give
my exclusivity to someone who's going to
voluntarily put themselves in those
situations and by the way if you have me
and you're so happy with me why do you
need to do all of that
perfectly reasonable for a man to come
to the table and say those things guys
are afraid to say them oftentimes
because they're afraid of losing a woman
don't be afraid men to lose a woman who
behaves badly it will be an enormous
favor to you if you lose someone that
disrespects you consistently
don't be afraid of the loss